today's show is brought to you by
[ __ ] square cash square cash is
the absolute best way to pay people for
things period
you [ __ ] understand me sending
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly into
your bank account in seconds
download the free square cash app for
iPhone or Android now all right I don't
want to [ __ ] talk to you until you do
it what's up babies it's Chris D'Elia
you guys chilling or what you doing the
most chill are you doing the half chill
or are you busy today maybe you're
chilling a little bit like a chill you
can still chill while you're doing a
little bit doing a little bit of things
um you know uh this is the about 12
episode man look at the [ __ ] way we're
doing it that means we've been doing it
for three months dude every week for
three months that's long that's imagine
three months from now you don't even
know we're gonna be from three months
from now you guys might be you have
might have moved you have no idea you
might have picked up and moved you might
have broken up with your wife or your
husband you might have a baby on the way
in three months it's a long time is what
I'm trying to say so yeah and let's see
what what is happening in my life I'm
here in LA it's my last day in LA for a
while I'm going to go to Toronto
tomorrow to shoot a movie everything uh
everything got put on a reschedule for
me because I have to go do this for my
career
and I'm very sorry to Australia I'm very
sorry too I'm not sure I think I'm gonna
have to reschedule Arizona and possibly
West Palm Beach and I'm very sorry but I
will reschedule it but um
so yeah I've been I've been performing
in Los Angeles and I love Toronto so I'm
super excited to be there it's probably
my favorite city outside of Los Angeles
or New York more details on what I'm
shooting later I won't get into it now
but I'm just happy to get [ __ ] so far
away from Los Angeles because of the
second week of Coachella I I know it's
not in Los Angeles I know it's in Indio
or whatever um you know Coachella is the
worst thing I think and I about it a
little bit briefly on the last podcast
but now it's it's happening so now it's
like completely in the red zone and
people are just over too and I want to
respond to some people about people get
upset at people think Hotel is stupid
some people do a lot of people like it
and go but people are [ __ ] you know
why do we go like why do they why do
they go and make it a [ __ ] scene and
got to get dressed up and but the people
get the most mad are the people who are
mad at people for getting for making fun
of it and that means that you give a
[ __ ] what people say which is fine we
all give a [ __ ] what people say but you
can't say let us just have our fun
because this is our fun
you understand you get to do your shitty
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] and I get to do the [ __ ]
where I make fun of it you don't get to
[ __ ] go to Coachella and have me not
talk about it bye
you don't get to do that put on your
boots put on your frilly [ __ ] thing
put rhinestones above your eyebrows
color your hair blue put on a stupidest
[ __ ] scarecrow hat dress like goddamn
Pocahontas and go have a good time and I
get to call you [ __ ] stupid that's it
that's how it goes you don't get to say
you know why does everybody just let us
let us have fun have fun
go have fun you [ __ ] big idiot let me
be my type of idiot
I don't give a [ __ ] go out go take Molly
and drink all the [ __ ] and [ __ ] dance
around a [ __ ] speaker - kendrick
lamar or whoever or some band Radiohead
do it but you you get two you get two
and here's the other thing - you're
going to post about it
it's a why do people get so mad somebody
on Facebook was saying why do you get so
mad at not not to me just why do people
get so mad when P they poke their post
their pictures Coachella pictures
because if you really haven't that much
fun you're not [ __ ] taking pictures
and posting them what's the most fun
stuff sex a lot of people would say sex
is the best thing who's the [ __ ] is
taking pictures during sex and posting
it you don't do that because you're not
thinking of taking pictures because
you're thinking about bust and knots
that's why if you're busting a nut hey
if you're taking pictures at Coachella
and you're having so much fun the next
time you bust a nut snap that when
you're busting a nut here's what you're
thinking
can't wait to post it up on Instagram
nah dude don't [ __ ] you know what I
mean
and uh people get so mad at they're
having fun and then the other people are
looking at them having fun making fun of
them that's my fun that's also my job by
the way it's why I do what I do I don't
like uh but I figured that Coachella is
I think Coachella I don't like the herd
mentality
I think Coachella is the number one
thing in my life that I is on my you
know uh in my outside my group of
friends group of friends deal with this
the most Coachella that's the thing in
my life that that bugs me the most is
Coachella now I know I'm a [ __ ] yeah
I'm talking about funny bug I'm not
talking about like obviously there's
some real issues in the world but
if you're you know that it's the thing
in my life that works me the most
because it's got all the things I don't
like it's 107 degrees people are dressed
like Pocahontas white people and then
you're out there listening to a [ __ ]
band that you don't really give a [ __ ]
about and pretending like you are and
you're doing it with a million people
that's the thing that bugs me that's
that [ __ ] I don't like because just I I
don't know man
if you really are liking it having a
good time then you're just you're just
having a good time put your [ __ ]
phone down you know when I take my phone
out wooden board is [ __ ] that's what I
do and you know what it's a lot it's a
lot of the time board is [ __ ] a lot you
know why because I'm talking to people
that you know they're just saying [ __ ]
and I'm like all right come with some
real [ __ ] but if you're if you're at
Coachella you got your phone out you're
not experiencing it I know I'm not
saying anything I'm [ __ ] I know not
say anything new I know not say anything
you haven't heard before but so Kendrick
Lamar's album came out in the past week
I I haven't listened to it but uh you
know I imagine someone saying they don't
like Kendrick Lamar imagine that imagine
that [ __ ] happening imagine someone
being like ah yeah it's just not good I
I haven't heard it but I cannot believe
the wrath that person if I if I tweeted
[ __ ] cat and I don't think this but
if I tweeted [ __ ] Kendrick Lamar
sucks
do you met could you imagine could you
imagine if not somebody out
I think if Donald Trump tweeted [ __ ]
Kendrick Lamar it would be over I know
and he's done a lot of [ __ ] that people
don't like if he tweeted that he'd be
impeached
that would be the thing didn't really
like the album damn he could write he'd
be gone
tomorrow we'd have [ __ ] pension
they're like da da woo
you know what do i do um but I got off
could I got off track a little bit I
would I would I think about the the like
here's the thing I don't like to do a
lot of things and and people say my
friends like I don't like like for
instance Coachella okay or or listening
to a new album isn't an experience I
really give a [ __ ] about going back to
Kendrick Lamar uh and people say let's
go let's go do this thing to me my
friends and I say no I don't want to and
then they say you're boring and uh I
completely [ __ ] disagree with this
okay
I completely disagree with this I think
the least boring people do nothing and I
know that that nobody [ __ ] would
would say it would agree with that
but here's the thing if you're a boring
person you need stimulation if you're a
boring person you have to go to
Coachella it's it's not an option to not
go because you can't sit with your
[ __ ] mind because you're boring and
you think about stuff like fruit and
you're a [ __ ] boring person and you
look at the ground and you don't even
think you're just like looking at the
dirt and you're like ha ha look at a
grass and the dirt cuz you're boring
because you didn't [ __ ] grow up right
that's why so you need things like
Coachella to keep stimulated you need to
look at [ __ ] things and hear it all
and [ __ ] put on stupidest [ __ ] star
sunglasses and put rhinestones above
your eyebrows because those are things
to do that keep you entertained you dolt
do alt okay so if you're if you're not
boring you can sit and have a blast
because you're in your [ __ ] head
thinking about the [ __ ] that entertains
you you don't need stimulation cuz you
not Barracuda
you ever see a barracuda on a boat see a
[ __ ] bracelet it goes nuts sweat jar
if yet Coachella
Swach are you Barracuda hey ya Coachella
Swach are you Barracuda mmm human you
CUDA you need stimulation you CUDA mmm
human okay
I mean dude you don't need that you
don't play frisbee golf you coud young
go watch y'all go watch the Celtics you
CUDA you gonna play Scattergories you
CUDA mmm dolt D ult okay not dolt dolt
I'm not dolt dolt okay yeah
that's that's the thing that's the
opposite of boring is not doing things
you think Stephen Hawking and I'm not
you know but you think Stephen Hawking
bored as [ __ ]
now dude that guy's figuring [ __ ] out
I'm surprised that guy doesn't come in
his [ __ ] pants every day just like my
found out something else in bird I found
something else out that's him coming mmm
dolt Burke you khuda burp you need
stimulation new kuda
ah [ __ ] them definitely going to hell
but this is the [ __ ] I think of and this
is why I'm not boring I'm not boring you
say I don't go want to go hang gliding
I'm not boring I don't need to feel that
[ __ ] I don't need to go out there I got
[ __ ] to think about like what you know
like likes and dislikes and what's going
on in my life and who I am part of me I
don't want to put on boots and a [ __ ]
frilly jacket part of me I don't want to
listen to the new Yonsei album you know
no knock on her got [ __ ] to figure out
got likes and dislikes to figure out is
what it is dude here what do you guys
saying I posted a thing on Instagram
about I reposted this girl who wrote who
said some stuff about consciousness
everybody's got a voice now and that's
how it is and you know she posted a
video somebody sent it to me and I
reposted it and I wrote hey finally
somebody said all this preach on sister
but one more thing what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and I don't know somebody
said I shouldn't repost it but she
posted it so I just reposted it I didn't
[ __ ] smash her up I just said what
are you talking about I don't think it's
a bad thing you want to hear what she
said here's what she said
just for five minutes loud yourself to
drop everything that was ever given to
you including your name your religion
drop your name there's some time your
sex guess I'm neither mailing for your
identity if you drop your identity shut
I'm not back man
first off what's left um [ __ ] here
consciousness travels Oh consciousness
consciousness is left okay it's what
makes up everything that's space between
your breasts the space between your
heartbeats the thing that's observing me
thinking the things I'm serving you
watching this video right now is the
same thing in me as it isn't you the
trees wait a minute
as it is in life trees separateness both
oh sorry wait a minute imagine if just
for a day no oh it Luke see I couldn't
tell because it was all the same thing
um so she posted that and and I got it I
read it I heard it and I sat down um
because I don't now people are like
people comment under my thing and
they're like that's true though not the
point at all the point is I think the
main point is why the [ __ ] are you
saying this right now to your to people
to to the to the people why are you
posting this but I didn't understand I
it and so I just put it what the [ __ ]
okay so matter for a day okay I got a
day in my head right now
oh [ __ ] just got way shorter five
minutes my pants
all right so Chris not Chris not just
I'm not a guy okay I'm not Brooke though
okay that's you um a shirt and socks
and hair hair how far down are we
getting here consciousness Oh
let me ask a question young drugs it's
what makes up the space between your
breath the space between your heart the
space between your breath is it black my
position don't say - nope see the trees
things really yeah what'd I just say
words like is that support I'm genuinely
curious not trying to you know roast is
is it help is she is helping uh you put
some on the Internet's on the Internet
you know what I mean had to be hi do you
guys think that that lady was hi had to
be right
imagine super just one sec imagine for
d'agneau imagine for know imagine for
five minutes not figure it out before
you start shooting you know let's get
the timeline straight before you start
shooting
she starts rolling too early that's my
problem imagine just for a day no you
know what imagine for five minutes start
after imagine for a year you know what
imagine for four days
Madden for four days let's do for four
days that just for one second imagine
for a day for a second that you drop
everything you are you drop your your
name you're not you just leave it behind
you drive your pants you drop your socks
you got your dick out you got no
underwear you drop it and what are you
you lose you are you are you know what
you are you're human your consciousness
that's what's left your consciousness
the same thing that's in between your
breath the same thing that's in between
the trees the same thing that's in
between your balls was in between your
tits in between your two ass cheeks your
[ __ ] consciousness constantly
that's what you have I'm gonna post a
video like that um but these people I'm
gonna just go to these I'm gonna go to
put a bunch of hashtags on there um
here's a hashtag conscious being here's
something here's something on see I'm
just going to I went to the hashtag
conscious being and I'm just going to
look at some of this stuff on conscious
being like there's all of a sudden guess
what came up when I hit that hashtag 9
million quotes ok people love quotes
because if you put a quote out on the
Internet you feel like you did something
even though you did absolutely nothing
more important than taking a [ __ ] in
matter of fact you did something less
important than taking a [ __ ] if you put
a quote on Instagram you did something
less important than releasing bowels
because you got to do that to make room
for more food so you can live longer but
if you put quotes on an Instagram you
did something less important than flying
[ __ ] out of your ass so congratulations
here are a bunch of quotes our outer see
this is what I don't and I'm not even I
didn't read this quote yet but my
prediction is this is not something
these quotes every court I'm going to
read right now is some [ __ ] that
everybody already knows and you either
[ __ ] do it or you don't like you're
not nobody's [ __ ] like whoever said
this millions of years at night and you
know thousands of years ago it was the
first guy that said it after that nobody
needed to say that [ __ ] anymore cuz we
all knew it's just such basic [ __ ] here
we go our outer lives are a projection
of our inner beliefs and attitudes who
the [ __ ] doesn't know that who doesn't
know that ok so let me put in the
layman's terms even though it
already in there whatever we do is
because of whatever we think we should
do cool
there you go that's my quote here's
another one when we simply shift from
please to thank you
everything changes no [ __ ] you know why
because please is a different word than
thank you you change the words things
change
hey here's my quote for that if you
change words things change here's
another one this is all under conscious
being by the way darkness has no power
it is merely the absence of light by
turn round dude if you [ __ ] read
darkness has no power it is merely the
absence of light and you think wow turn
round here's another one our
consciousness can hear yo yo
consciousness this is a big thing our
consciousness can only expand when we
question what we believe to be true so
let's say quit me questioning what I
believe to be true I believe quotes like
this are [ __ ] stupid so let's think
okay for a second this quote isn't isn't
isn't stupid so that's why I'm
questioning maybe I'm wrong and maybe
these quotes are important okay so I did
that um now my consciousness expanded is
expanding now I guess because I just did
that so I don't I don't know maybe in a
few days I just oh here's the one that
pisses me right off whatever the
question the answer is always love hey
can I have some orange juice love oh
you're crazy can I have a
can Hey Dude do you mind giving me a
ride to the airport
love lunatic dude if somebody responded
to a question of mine with love imagine
just for a sec imagine for a day
imagine [ __ ] now imagine for one second
somebody responded to a question with
love in between my heartbeats in between
the two testicles I have in my sack in
between the trees in between two pieces
of [ __ ] if somebody takes a [ __ ] and
another prediction [ __ ] next to in
between there will we have that
consciousness the answer is always love
you're not saying anything
hey when somebody says stuff like that
this is my new response I was
interesting farted in your face with my
face Scimitar the internet [ __ ]
everything up I mean it's great it's I
think and the whole it's a good thing
but II everyone has a voice and that's
good but don't use it that much you're
diluting everything you use your voice
too much nobody gives a [ __ ] stop doing
hashtags and then just doing nothing I
[Music]
got mad at myself
did a hashtag like a few months ago an
important one and then I realized I
haven't done [ __ ] since I did that
hashtag up to make it better
piece of [ __ ] for that what's that
so what did I just put it out in the
[ __ ] universe and then someone else
saw the hashtag and thought yeah he's
right and then what and then what
nothing [ __ ] I didn't change anything
I didn't [ __ ] that's bad of me that's
it's a waste of time if I if if you ever
if there's a [ __ ] movement going on
and somebody's like if somebody say all
of a sudden we find out that cantaloupes
[ __ ] make cancer happen and that like
say oh there's cancer because of
cantaloupes that's why and then
everyone's like we got to get rid of
cantaloupes and then other people like
but cantaloupes are so good they taste
so good [ __ ] that and then I'm like on
Twitter and I'm like remove all
cantaloupes and that's the hashtag I do
and then no and then I just do what I do
I go on tour I come back I hang on I
have coffee with my friends I have a few
meetings and nishan down I do nothing to
get rid of cantaloupes
I'm piece of [ __ ] I'm a dick I'm a
[ __ ] time waster I'm what they call
virtue signaling right it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
you all I did was make a tweet that
[ __ ] however many followers I have
saw and maybe some people tweeted it
some that that are against cantaloupes
and they didn't do [ __ ] either I didn't
do anything about it I'm a piece of [ __ ]
hi if I do that I'm a piece of [ __ ] and
I've done that before
and I'm not doing it again do something
you just you use your voice so much and
don't do anything about it your voice
doesn't matter dude your voice doesn't
matter so you can go on in Instagram
talk about consciousness talk about in
[ __ ] space between your heartbeats
but it doesn't matter this is what
you're doing
daddy you WAP the wah wah wah that's
what you're saying
because it doesn't matter what you're
doing is basically breathing
I didn't mean for this to turn into a
TED talk but it is um that's it square
cash you understand me square cash is
the best way to pay people for stuff
period I've said it before I'm saying it
again you can do rest you can pay for
rest you know you go to coffee with your
friends you say Oh Shh
you know [ __ ] I owe you five bucks let
me just zoom it to you right now with
square cash ding split the tab whatever
like I said you got if you ask somebody
now I don't suggest you do this but you
ask somebody uh maybe some like really
[ __ ] fierce mafia-style guy hey I
need you to spit in someone's face then
the guy says that's gonna be 25 dollars
and be like I'll just square cash it to
you then he spits it in her face he does
it and then you just go ding square
couchguy twenty twenty-five dollars for
the Mafia move me I'm saying and you can
download the square cash app for iOS or
Android now square cash is better than
all the other ones they get out you know
it's just quick and it's on the Apple
App Store and it's on Google Play App
Store so if you don't have it you're
kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you
gonna do reach in your wallet and look
for a little how much was it at forty
five dollars
let me see if I have it you have change
for it now you don't need change you
just take it from phone to phone and
that's it and it's so easy I I have it I
use it so do it by the way I block
everyone that says that they hate that I
do ads on my show because you don't get
the you don't your word hey hey go to
work for free and go to work for free
hey go do what you do don't get paid go
do that then
you can complain about listening to my
podcasts without and wish that there
weren't ad
you gotta you gotta this is America dude
this is how every [ __ ] country works
pretty much even it unit tribe its how
it works
you gotta get something you got give
something to get some you given time
giving you add space hmm have you heard
about the little Aussie vert well first
of all why is every rapper lil what is
that I don't know it's been like that
for a while - its but music is more and
more hoozy vert I don't know what that
is little if I was a rapper and I'm the
furthest thing from a rapper but if I
was a rapper I the last thing I'd want
is to have a name like someone else's
name right they're all like [ __ ] dead on
this [ __ ] but yo we got the same name no
but yo is meet us this [ __ ] not you
every rap song is like I'm the best you
ain't [ __ ] but we got to say nay no lil
Uzi vert has a new Marilyn Manson chain
reportedly worth 220,000 dollars this is
from alternative press calm
it may seem unexpected about rapper lil
Uzi vert loves Marilyn Manson so much
that he got a 55 karat black and white
diamond Marilyn Manson pendant oh my god
I don't um I mean do
good that's not cool I mean look Marilyn
Manson is kind of the [ __ ] like his
music was [ __ ] poppin but like what
the [ __ ] yeah look at this [ __ ] two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars I
don't know how much does this guy have
lil Uzi vert I don't want to do you know
little Aussie vert Network net I mean
this is always wrong
three million estimated net worth of
three million dollars and he paid two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars for
a Marilyn Manson chain that you can't
resell who the [ __ ] he gonna sell it
to Marilyn Manson that's [ __ ] that's
like one twelfth of his [ __ ] net
worth which means he doesn't have that
which means that's including like his
house I guess you're gonna go bankrupt
hey man did you learn anything from
other rappers in history lil Uzi vert oh
my god well I mean maybe he didn't pay
that much for it but lil Uzi vert gonna
be a little bankrupt in a little bit huh
hey the guy's gonna have to change his
name to little bankrupt lil Uzi vert
gonna have to change his name to a
little bit of money in his bank account
you know hey lil Uzi vert you only got a
little bit of money in your bank account
but you got big chain that can't sell
cuz it's of a Marilyn Manson's face
imagine what that conversation was like
a jeweler what up I want to chain and
jewelers like alright what do you want
yo is gonna be custom first of all
second of all
I don't know what I want but I know I'm
a [ __ ] hell a big Marilyn Manson fan
and then the jeweler was like oh well uh
do you want to maybe like do something
where we is I can owed to him or like
one of his maybe like a pendant that
says sweet dreams or some [ __ ] or the
beautiful people and then little Lucifer
one like this [ __ ] now doc I want
Marilyn Manson's face on my chest player
because ain't nothing realer to having
another man's face under my face yo
that's weird
E that's like some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
somebody's face around your neck you're
like that's like saying hey this person
that's I that blows my mind that's like
that joke I had were you [ __ ] on the
incorrigible about how you figure out a
sports team name on your back that guy
gets to [ __ ] you I mean dude I'm
crystally I can't imagine having another
dudes face anywhere maybe let maybe a
t-shirt you know but something I paid
two hundred and twenty thousand dollars
for that guy's got like probably got to
go to therapy lil Uzi vert you know I
mean you probably I go to therapy if you
paid that much to put somebody's face on
your chest I don't know what for but you
supply something going on there
I'm gonna check these hashtags right now
see how many of you guys are trying to
gain the system I got one here mark guru
at mark Sheng go that's fine
trying to game the system what advice do
you have for single guys in 2017 I think
it's weird when single guys want advice
like you you figured it out you're
single you're you don't have to answer
to anybody you can just do whatever you
want and not explain yourself oh that's
oh I'm sorry dude you figured it out
what you want to get in a relationship
that's the problem I think if you want
to get into a relationship you got to
check yourself dude you get into a
relationship when you fall in love but
that's why is it to satisfy can people
or the people order like oh man I wish I
had a girlfriend had a boyfriend you sad
be happy you're chilling you doing what
you doing what you're doing
would tell what's advice how'd it what's
my advice whatever you're doing it
you're you're the one who gives advice
bro you know um oh here's a good one um
at Gap suriani and her thing is just a
heart which is kind of cold I guess
what's your most favorite song of all
time I think my most favorite song of
all time is never had a friend like me
by Tupac and it's off the gridlock
soundtrack uh I just think it's awesome
it's simple and it's [ __ ] good and
sick synced and he's just the [ __ ] and
he sound it sounds awesome I also like
me and my girlfriend by Tupac which is
where he's talking about the gun slash
girl um I love that song KK Foster 9 is
butter still limping no no no because
things heal
um so yeah let's look at some other ones
here uh here's a good one from mattress
Kenny which is at Kendall Blake a what
you can hear you you Kendall Blake do it
mattress Kenny change it at underscore
Kendall Blake mattress
Kenny change it [ __ ] guy at Chris Lea
doesn't ever get annoying being spotted
in public yeah of course it does
that's I always [ __ ] think of when I
was when I was in high school there was
this 50-cent lyric when he was ed and he
says if you see me tell me you love me
don't stare at me my and I always
thought wouldn't he rather them not come
up to him and bother him then [ __ ]
tele wouldn't if they're just staring at
him then it's it's not a thing you know
it's not a intrusive but it's way more
annoying when somebody [ __ ] stares at
you from across the way at like Pete's
coffee and they're like looking at their
phone and checking if it's you than it
is if you just come up and say hey big
fan and now I get it now that I'm
equally as famous as 50 cent I get it um
was a joke but um ya know uh it's
yeah I would say 80% of the time
somebody comes up to me and gives me a
compliment it's backhanded and I mean
80% and it's unbelievable people want to
prove how much they're a fan of yours so
they they'll say [ __ ] like my friend
said you weren't funny but I [ __ ]
told them I set him straight and you're
like yo get better at telling
compliments man this [ __ ] guy came up
to me let the other night he goes I
guess hey Chris D'Elia man you're pretty
funny hey man don't [ __ ] be so blasé
about it neither tell me and mean it or
don't hey man
you're pretty funny oh cool man that's
like hey you want a salad sure yeah
whatever
oh you don't really like salads yeah
they're pretty good like don't do it
it's why he's like ah cool eyes I
alright man thanks but I guess you know
he was like yeah man he was like oh man
then he said oh man you you're so
annoyed right he's like oh man sorry I'm
annoying you and I was like ah you're
not annoying me it's all good he was
like ah cool man yeah I watched you
seemed you do a bunch of shows and I was
like ah that's cool man and he's like
huh okay man well it's [ __ ] really
awkward huh and I'm not and I said yeah
well you're if you if you're making it
awkward yeah I mean I'm not oh I don't
feel awkward and he was like oh man oh
well dude I just want to tell you you're
funny I'm a big fan I said yeah dude
thanks bro and he was like okay and he
said wool I don't know why it's weird
and I was like well what will you keep
saying the same thing over and over
again and it's all good but thank you I
appreciate it I literally couldn't
figure out what the [ __ ] to say to the
guy and then his friend came up to him
and he was like yo man let's get out of
here man you're you know like like leave
him alone and I was like it's all good
you know whatever and he was like you
want me to leave you alone and I'm like
I mean I said to him I said I mean I
don't know you know like or you can say
other things if you want or you could
just leave like it's not a really huge
not a huge deal and then of course I
look like a dick because I'm like come
on guy but like you understand what
you're [ __ ] doing dude for and also
he was drunk and then at the end he was
like - but dude I'm just trying to tell
you man that like even when other people
say you aren't funny
I tell them I say like you're funny and
I said - I said to his friend I said hey
man you got to tell this you got to get
this guy better at giving [ __ ]
compliments and then he [ __ ] walked
away with all [ __ ] smile he was like
huh and then that guy's gonna go tweet
about how I was an [ __ ] you know the
guy made it completely [ __ ] weird and
here's the other thing I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't care at all
make it weird but I'm gonna [ __ ] say
yo you're being a weirdo
when you see me to me let me don't stare
Minmei
I mean just [ __ ] come up be like hey
great job good job I'm a big fan if it's
anything more than that you don't have
to come up hey I don't even know who you
are but can I get a pic No
bye the [ __ ] you want to take a picture
with some guy you don't know who is
weird it's weird I sometimes I say that
to people can I take a pic with you I
say Who am I and if they say haha I say
no if I Know Who I am I'll take a pic
with you and I'm the deck right ha ha ha
hey can I a monopoly is your [ __ ]
time for about 25 seconds so my
Instagram is poppin umm yeah man
this person's asking me it is a good
question to talk about Coachella at tall
Heather cool
you better be tall if you're not tall
change it how much money would it have
to be if you were asked to do stand-up
at Coachella dude if you're asked to do
stand-up at Coachella it would be
literally be I don't care who it is
doing it you would [ __ ] eat [ __ ] you
would bomb so hard I would never do
stand-up at Coachella you'd have to give
me you'd have to give me God that's a
good question you'd have to give me a
million [ __ ] dollars dude I wouldn't
do it for less than that because I think
honestly you'd be taking a [ __ ] huge
hit in your career nobody would laugh it
would look awful online everyone would
be snapping it and putting it on [ __ ]
Twitter I think you'd have to give me
more than a million dollars to do it to
be totally honest I'm telling you right
now if Coachella was like we're going to
give you $800,000 to do this I would
actually say no and then when people we
like but I want to see you I'd be like
sauce bro
I'd be like sauce a I'd literally say
sauce yeah um yeah man I mean that's
just that's just career suicide
somebody just tweeted me this [ __ ]
picture that I think BuzzFeed put out
when this guy asked us go to prom D this
is [ __ ] hilarious I'll tweet the
picture but this is I laughed really
hard at this this sign and he's got this
guy on his arm around his girl and he's
holding the sign where I asked her go to
prom with her and the sign reads this is
what it reads you'll run the all b-12
I'd love to take a shot at prom
number one two with you you'll run
you'll run the all be warned you'll run
the I'd love to take a shot I get that
I'll be at prom with you you'll run the
one two I'll be at prom with you you'll
run the one two
I'd love to take a shot at prom with you
but what about I'll be this I got a
tweet this [ __ ] thing how [ __ ]
stupid do you have to be to make this
sign I'm sorry I don't give a [ __ ] he's
in high school dude who me you'll run
the I'll be one it could be I'll be one
I'd love to to take a shot at I don't
have a [ __ ] clue what this means and
I got a tweet it and she said yes this
[ __ ] girl looked at this sign and
says yes she didn't know what the [ __ ]
she's agreeing to cool you just agreed
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you wait
what that's what the sign says you
didn't read it I tried I got a tweet
this [ __ ] thing um all right that's
it I got to go to Toronto dude um really
appreciate all you guys listening
remember uh I have some stuff coming up
I've got my special man on fire coming
up late June in on Netflix you can
support the podcast by going to store
Chris D'Elia com
there's some stuff there high quality
made in Los Angeles my babies I got some
[ __ ] crystally emerge on there is
very very cool you wear
and people look at you indigo like this
wow that's amazing tweet me at hashtag
congratulations pod and please honestly
rate reboot and review the show
sometimes how do you want to do this
[ __ ] show
if you rate review it and we're up in
the rankings and daddys [ __ ] backing
up more Brinks trucks and daddys gonna
[ __ ] do a lot of [ __ ] here and he's
going to do a lot more shows maybe even
do more shows might even do more than
one a week so rate review it please tell
your friends about it we get those
numbers up daddy's happy the babies are
happy you understand square cash don't
forget to download the free square cash
app for iOS or Android now thanks for
listening my babies and have a good